[Musik]
der pitztaler gletscher ist das
höchstgelegene skigebiet österreichs
[Musik]
die skisaison dauert hier bis in den mai
gleich drei restaurants kümmern sich um
das leibliche wohl der wintersportfans 1
auf der gletscher spitze in fast 3500
metern höhe die anderen auf knapp 3.000
eines der beliebtesten gerichte bei den
skifahrern der kaiserschmarrn
er gehört zu österreich wie die alpen
wunderbar wie meine großmutter da ist
jemand direkt neben den beiden
restaurants liegt österreichs
höchstgelegener konditorei hier kümmert
sich stefanie santala um die mehlspeisen
also auch neben kaiserschmarrn
wir produzieren hier oben alles selber
in der backstube also die ganze
süßspeisen ihnen zwei restaurants wild
spiel zugestand und auch das café 34 40
beliefern wir mit frisch torten und
strudel mied jeden morgen werden sie mit
der gondel zu österreichs
höchstgelegenem kaffeehaus dem café 34
40 hinauf geschickt es liegt noch einmal
600 meter höher als die backstube neben
dem fantastischen ausblick gibt es hier
noch eine besondere gaumenfreude die
gletscherschnee torte flockig sehr
dürftig
weil man die frisch nimmt ganz ganz
zauberhaft
doch das packen in der höhe birgt so
seine tücken
es ist eben dieser luftdruck schwieriger
probleme haben auf 2048 bit haben sie
auf 3 440 mit dem siedepunkt probleme
wenn wir das wissen das wetter um lässt
produzieren immer einen tag vorher die
bisher kann es sein dass sie nicht so
schön locker bern und aufgehen ein
kaiserschmarrn ist dagegen nicht so
heikel was die zubereitung angeht und
auch den zutaten sind äußerst simpel
milch eier mehl zucker mehr braucht es
nicht
zunächst milch und mehl mission dann die
eier trennen und das eiweiß mit etwas
zucker steif schlagen
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir auch schönes
angeschlagen oder gerieben
so soll es sein
die restlichen eier mit der mehl milch
masse mission dann das ist wichtig für
die luftige konsistenz des kaisers manns
vorsichtig den eischnee unterheben
wir hier oben am pitztaler gletscher
vermerk mineralwasser im teig
nehmt lieber weiß dass das eiweiß macht
es nicht zur druck- und den
kaiserschmarren doch bleibt dann
vielleicht als jetzt kann man hier
rosinen reim machen wir hier am bbi zwei
wochen mit rosinen
man kann auch ruhig ohne rosinen machen
wir brauchen in der wintersaison an die
vierte und kaiserschmarren das heißt an
spitzentagen braucht mehr zwischen 150
und 200 stück portionen fünf minuten
muss der kaiserschmarrn auf jeder seite
packen dann ist er fertig stefanie
sandte liefert die restaurants auch mit
wiener apfelstrudel und palatschinken
[Musik]
von einer missglückten palatschinken
einen dünnen eierkuchen soll der
kaiserschmarren auch seinen namen haben
denn der österreichische kaiser franz
josef nick des speicher war allerdings
sein lieblings bisher die palatschinken
zerrissen durfte die dienerschaft den
schmarrn also den unsinn auslöffeln
ein glück denn so wurde das pannen
gericht als kaiserschmarrn bekannt
[Musik]
jetzt fehlt nur noch dass starb zugkraft
der kaiserschmarrn
dazu servieren miroamer bizarre
chartmuster preiselbeer nicht nur im
tiroler pitztal zählt der zerrütten
kuchen zu den beliebtesten süßspeisen
der österreichischen küche
[Musik]